welcome everyone should play the people
and we're gonna play some blitz today
and I'll take it to you know with some
analysis as well and like what we did
last week and so you can save me a
challenge and you know probably prefer
something like three plus two so we
don't have like their flagging going on
here so not too much oh that so I'll
probably start out with this game
against nad and here we go
so again you challenge st. Louis Chess
Club account okay so I'll play with d4
and I'll be reading your you know you're
you know in a chat section I'll be
reading your questions and comments and
I'll try to answer as many as I can
while I'm playing so we have a Queens
gambit declined here and I play this
setup with Bishop g5 now I query
at the point is to go Bishop d3 get
development we should be tree I like to
play the bishop between IG to set up
with a long castle ideas so
Bishop g4
no g2
Quincy to the PI D has to play f 3e for
plan here normally you cast a short and
play 3/4 who we think is gonna win the
World Cup
well I was really really hoping Geoffrey
would have you know I get an amazing
result
Geoffrey shonky won the first four
rounds but then it was knocked out by
Tim watch Hawaii was really really
rooting for Geoffrey I've played a lot
of tournaments with him I really was
hoping he would go very deep end but
just didn't quite worked out that day in
a match against raja baath so that was
the guy was rooting for I was rooting
for my friend linear Dominguez of course
and I was hoping Wesley would have done
better but didn't quite work out so
unfortunately our American players
didn't qualify but yeah definitely
Geoffrey strong made a big statement in
this tournament by knocking out guys
like kiri Duda and you know showing that
he's you know he's getting very close to
challenge the elite so that was that was
really nice to see him do that who is
gonna win I'm probably have to go with I
just blundered upon actually on before
he couldn't take it earlier because if
you had taken earlier I dropped b1 and
rook takes b7 but now I just well I was
talking I just blundered he can take now
the pawn I'm hoping I would like to see
ding ding green but you know he is most
likely gonna qualify by reading already
so Dean we're an or or mvl I think one
of these two guys I think will so it's
very likely we'll have a well whoever
wins this next match is already
qualified to do so this is like actually
even though this is a semi final is
actually the final in a sense that you
qualify to candidate tournament if you
win it so
we'll see obviously raja baath and young
here are very motivated because you know
they're they're not gonna be able to
qualify by reading so they need to
really win this and also for mal he
missed out he missed out two years ago
qualifier so we'll see so what happened
here well I think I'm just probably
winning now my opponent you know when I
played this b5 I was already better and
he just allowed this capture on CA twice
I mean he's got some tricks he's trying
to do he's got a couple of tricks but
overall it's just probably not gonna
work for him so um okay let's see what
we do here start out with like rook c8
see one
just want to consolidate my position I
don't want to give up any material when
you're winning it the key is to
consolidate so if they dad always take
on a son
now here's take and take eliminate that
past bond so we don't have to deal with
the past pounding down on the board
don't ignore this past parts if you
ignore them they're gonna push down it's
gonna be tough but don't ignore them now
Bishop c4 okay what's going on here
you should be tool just to play it safe
I don't want any hanging pieces there on
a six
I'll probably just play G 3G v g3
getting aloft check
Bishop c4 f7 is the target so and now we
dig
check that way we give a check and pick
up the pollen h6
kingi for and he resigned here all right
so we got the first wing guys let's take
a look at some of the questions a lot of
the friends and fans Morphy Paul Morphy
what's European polar yeah I've been
absolutely brilliant player Paul Morphy
and he played some really really great
really great chess and you know but
again and back in the day was very
different than the chess right now
nowadays it's like computerized it's a
very very modern so different chess
let's see let's see can anyone play yeah
I mean you just need to get in a line
and challenge me
let's see what do I think of vicious
shot getting candidates I would love to
see Bishop play he is a good friend of
mine and I you know met Fischer here in
st. Louis and over the years he's been
coming here so I really really root for
him and I wish he qualified I'll be so
nice you know to see him back in a
candidates tournament Jeffrey now won't
and well well yeah well if you did
Jeffrey had won he would have faced nvl
it would have been a tough task but he
would have been just one match away you
know I thought he had chances against
Roger both I just you know I think
perhaps his last round game you know it
was just a very sharp room felt and he
was doing okay just got into the heavy
attack there so you know that's what
happens you know you loo you know you
lose the second game the first game is
drawing you're just out there is not
much time to even recover so one bad
move can actually you know eliminate you
from the tournament yes you can
definitely play just need to challenge
and let's start with another game let's
see we got 30 people already in line
guys so this is pretty awesome here so
we got what's the time control this game
unlimited wait I don't know if this we
cannot play unlimited time control game
I think we got up we gotta play three
plus two guys so so if you're sending me
a challenge you want to play you want to
change that to three plus two so we can
just you know so I'm gonna accept this
challenge here and we have
Randy Lee Hartley lehigh so let's see so
okay let's try some French here let's
see how our opponent will handle the
French you probably know I've been a
French player for a very very long time
so c5 I take
all right guys wait what's going on okay
all right so we got the French defenses
Bishop d3 line here so let's see putting
pressure on d4 okay let's just play some
simple exchange variation
we should be six
ninety-seven
castles
the six to eight-week adjustment yeah
okay so I go Bishop f5 trying to trade
the bishop so you know the French
defense you always try to get rid of the
light square bishop here so let's see
here
Who am I personally rooting for in a
World Cup well I'm from the players left
I really like Dingley Rennes and you
know I would like dink to win it he's a
great player and a very very nice person
so I would I would love to see ding win
it so he came close two years ago but he
lost in the final two Aronian so from
the players remaining I'm rooting for
Dingley Wren to win the whole thing he
just played in st. Louis and a sink
filled Cup he was here and I you know
spend some time with him you know and
he's a great player so I hope he can win
it but anybody else wins it that's you
know they all deserved winners you know
anybody who goes so deep in a World Cup
I mean they deserve to win it or at
least you know qualify to the candidate
tournament because I've played
personally in this tournament a couple
of times it's very very tough the best
I've done it I've won the first round
so I played three four times and again
my best was I went I won the first round
basically even winning the first round
is extremely tough because there are no
easy opponents okay so let me see here
what we have some French defence
exchange variation structure here not
much is happening I I play b5 here just
to stop 94 95 I mean
so I go rocky eight
five
okay so let's see can I take all the
four take take and I take on d1 I mean
this is interesting let's see
take take
now if I move my knight he's gonna take
it so I'm gonna yes I don't have much in
this position it's a pretty equal here
so far guys yes you can trade Queens
Roxy for
I want to play Quint xh3 here we take
say three takes Knight f3 trick but the
problem is guys Quint x HD has Queen d4
tactic that would have been so nice if
Queen h3 worked you know probably have
to play some defensive move now okay
okay so so far he's not really
threatening anything
but I'm kind of tangled up here I can I
just move my pieces so looking f7 I
don't know if I should taking f7 it's
just right just in case endgame happens
I'll be closer so very close game very
close game so far so we take and
okay gonna bring this look back here
guys there is a queen h5 threat it's
pretty annoying actually to deal with
this let's just age six to six push past
bounds meant to be pushed so we try to
push them
h4 h5 fixing and I don't want to allow
h5 mm-hmm push push
check
again at the end of the day guys the
pass pawned that loan passed pawn
decides the outcome of this game okay
here we have it there we go guys so
let's see if we have some a lot of lot
of comments let's see some people asking
questions okay
are we going to upload lectures yes we
recorded a lecture yesterday and it was
one of my games it's some you know a
middle game and endgame teams so
yesterday we recorded it and it's gonna
be uploaded soon
let's see any other okay yes let's see
if any other interesting questions
before we play there well you gotta be
in a queue you know I I just go by the
people and the queue and you know as
long as it's the time control that three
plus two is fine yeah let's see
okay let's see who we have here Wow we
got 56 people already in in line and
let's see what we have here who we have
here let's see we have some strong
opponent here let's see here
oops they go back and we just need to
accept
okay Mahmoud 69 all right let's see here
so we play d4 now let's see what is
Mahmoud going to play d5 c4 take
Bishop f4
we be three
what do you be seven pawn is under
attack
now check
now my opponent made a mistake so I go
Knights refers if I put in pressure
now I will
Castle yeah I'm basically I'm to tempies
ahead in opening so it's looking really
good for me here right now I probably
missed it oh I missed a simple 96 Bush
base six not not not playing that great
so far
missing a couple of simple things I'm
not too happy yeah I could have just
taken on c6 and Bishop a6 guys and just
win the exchange so it happens sometimes
you not as sharp when you start playing
the Blitz you know luckily I still have
a good position so
can take
okay now I think he's blundering stuff
so let's see take
- hick
Queen h4 not sure what is my opponent
trying to do so let's get the rook on a
seventh rank
and when you're ahead guys never afraid
to trade okay so you want to initiate
the trades
I like this I quite like f3 it's
restricts everything stops
efore stops g4 I have clean g5 coming up
and trade the Queen's always a good idea
to trade quits when you're up exchanging
upon we exchange Queens cake bring the
rock into the game
and we take poor pounds
okay let's see here
[Music]
check
that should be it guys that should be it
so yeah now those dollars no except that
moment I missed ninety-six and Bishop
takes but it was bros pretty good oh
let's see here where we have well yeah
this is not a my account guys I just
just the Chess Club account that we have
different people play on it so it's not
my personal account let's see here what
other questions you have for me maybe
let's see we might have big Q guys we
got like 70 people in line already like
so we're gonna try to get as many games
as possible I'm just looking through the
chart to see if there's some interesting
questions you want you have for me let's
see
blitz banter match yeah thank you yeah
I'm excited yeah let's see greetings
from Croatia yes hello hello and always
wanted to visit Croatia so I haven't
been there it's one of my countries in
the bucket list to visit Croatia I would
like to go there sometime okay I guess
we're gonna move on to the next game
guys what what tips I have for beginners
guys the beginner players just make sure
you control the center okay and develop
your pieces and you know get your
counsel your safety and get every piece
you have into the game okay so that's
right I would recommend so we have a
strong player here in a queue here so
we're gonna take a challenge
whoo 2,100 2,100 opponent we have guys
that's a strong very strong opponent
here so let's take a look win the test
with d4 okay
a banter blitz of what is my plan I
don't know I don't know much about it I
know I got invited into and I I am I'm
excited about that that match so I don't
know too much about I know it's gonna be
fun and Magnus is playing so should be
fun okay let's do something fun guys I
don't normally do this move f4 but it's
a blitz game we can have some fun you
know play some f4 and Knight of 395 well
it's preparation I don't know if I'm
gonna do some heavy preparation guys
it's a blitz match so I'm just gonna
play what I normally play and is the
debt is do they have the date already
set for the bunker blitz match because I
know that I should check in to see if
they have a date actually set for that
when is that going to take place okay I
go Bishop d2
a three
I take
castle
let's say here we go Quincy - yeah I
don't think I have much I don't think I
achieved much in the opening so we'll
see
okay no dated but it's against GM Paul
we are Paul yeah okay thank you for
letting me know
so as I understand it's like a World Cup
format right it's like a knockout format
we're gonna be playing and alright let's
get this night in here guys see what we
can do so if we can attack a little bit
here
let's get the rukon open file
Queen a7 what is he trying to do with 27
not sure I'll just pay there's no fear
trade Queens is good because we can win
the c6 fun I guess wait you just drop
the c6 fun yeah missing a lot of stuff
but still a very good position guys so
there we go there we have it
take
take
yeah this is a winning endgame
just get the king in
now the point is to put a night only
five guys and then just start pushing
the deep on
all right yep why twins nights are bad
at stopping passed pawns yeah let's see
if there are some more interesting
questions we have
well I will be doing it this Thursday
and next Thursday guys that's my last
name as a Grand Master in resident and
after that I'm getting ready to go to
Europe - plane Isle of Man feed a grand
Swiss tournament and it'll be a very
strong tournament I'm very excited about
it because you know a lot of top players
gonna be there including the world
champion so that's my next tournaments
after I will be here next Thursday doing
the stream and that's my last day as a
Grand Master resident and then I'm
getting ready ready ready to travel to
Europe to play in that important event
so let's see yeah I can only L I feel
comfortable against benoni yes I
mentioned that I was having trouble
against active play and been on any
recommendations well that Bishop f4 line
against Ben only is good the one that
you put an eye on f3 c3 and Bishop f4
that's the good one ok studying any tips
on visualizing the board yeah when you
visualizing the board basically when you
guys playing you cannot just be focused
on one side of the body you have to make
sure you're looking at the whole board
okay the entire board and look for
opportunities okay so improving your
pieces and you have to have the whole
board under control so remember data
don't just focus on one side so you have
to visualize the whole board let's see
here
my highest feeder rating was 26 around
2680 about two years ago I achieved that
I had a really great run in 2017 so that
was my highest rating there so now I'm
back you know back I'm 26 25 after my
last tournament so I need to work my way
up but you know I'm motivated so we'll
see let's see
yeah I let's see yeah thank you for the
good wishes for my tournament guys yeah
I hope to play well you know it's good I
know it's gonna be very tough and strong
tournament but it's an opportunity to go
there and play against the world-class
players so why do I only play d4 as
white because that's what I've been
playing my career and I feel I
understand these positions
I mean I've played a foreign couple of
games but you know that's just not my
specialty so it takes a long time to
understand the opening the structure so
I feel like I owe those with d4 and only
French as block I mean I have played
different openings too I've played
caro-kann for a while I played some
other openings so it's but French is my
main specialty so yeah greetings from
Rio yes Rio de Janeiro yeah I was I have
was fortunate enough to be in Rio and it
was a lot of fun visiting about 10 years
ago I was in Rio actually I had a great
time and let's see I'm 18 years old 20
to 30 feet I read how to become and I am
it's it's tricky yeah you have to train
hard you you're probably gonna need a
coach somebody who will guide you it's
not gonna be that easy to just become an
IM on your own survive here a coach
helped me to get to that level once you
become an IM i feel like you can work
yourself up to become a gym on your own
but it's it's not easy to do it on your
own without without a coach ok so have I
ever considered YouTube channel or some
way of you can share your chest yeah
I've thought about it you know probably
gonna you know do some you know my have
my own YouTube channel and play games
and analyze some current tournament
games so that's something in you know on
the list you know to do let's see here
guys we have a lot of people in line so
let's get some more games going in so we
got a 2100
opponent here and we are a block so
let's see here so if you play C 4 I'll
play something a little bit different
than French so you can see that I can
play different openings yeah I'm glad to
see so many people in a chat and you
know very active asking questions so
let's play this Knight f6 here see how
it goes and we play the b6 kind of fun
opening so yeah I I am glad that I
inspire people to play the French it's a
it's a very interesting opening and you
once you master the opening you know how
to play then you're gonna have really
good results oh let's see
so what shook you this I feel about this
okay four he goes eh six I question him
what is my approach against French
exchange I just you know I don't panic
when people play for exchange I don't
think oh it's gonna be a draw just I
just developed my pieces and try to look
for good opportunities okay what is
black doing here is very questionable he
is a weakening his dog scores and that's
not a good idea so we're gonna try to
attack his dark squares here guys so I
want to play a six this is to prevent
some night B five ideas so we don't want
to deal with maybe five and dark scores
are very very weak so my plan is
actually to go g6 and Bishop g7 okay
clean there
in 97
mm-hmm now we have the dark squares so
to a stick
the idea to get the night on see five
guys get the night on c5 and so we got
like we got like a really really good
Ben Oni here so it's like a Ben Oni it
at the best right now
now we attack tonight a lot of things
hanging here so let's see how he's gonna
do it now he blunder toward you see
Bishop d5 now the rock only one is
hanging
now we attack the Queen and
take care
all right let's get back to our let's
see a couple of questions we have French
caro-kann yeah play caro-kann one well
what aspects of chess do you study once
you get higher ready player well
definitely you have to work on your
middle game and your end games and do
some positional you know study some
positional games to make sure you
understand that area what is the best
way to defeat positional chess I mean
you you know you have to depending on a
position I mean if you know usually you
have to try to see if you can you know
create weaknesses and improve your
pieces it's it's hard depending on the
position I know I'm accepting any type
of games rated or round rated it doesn't
matter let's see here
let's see here
what is the key of Armenian chess
success it's it's the game is very
popular in Armenia so it's like its
treated like a sport and a lot of the
top Armenian players are onion they're
like you know they were very well
recognized and very popular so it's I
think that's you know Armenia always had
good history with chess and world
champion Tigran Petrosian so you know
people really like chess there so okay
let's play this Queens gambit declined
and I have some fun and play the
terrorists defense the opening I played
when I was growing up so let's see how
my opponent will handle this
all right let's do this
now if tonight goes back I'm gonna just
take on c5
can we go d3 here guys let's try it if
it takes we have before
no I think we win guys it worked out
fantastically this opening look at that
yeah he just missed a moment he didn't
take on before and now it's very strong
now we have night to see - he cannot be
defended
let's see I'll be coming back as a GM in
resident I believe sometime in November
so I'll be doing the stream again guys
so you'll see me again doing it you know
in November so Bishop check I go Bishop
d7 attack any Queen okay what's what is
he trying to do this night be free okay
let's just go here
and see where is the queen going
actually
take
we take
and now we open up the a file that's why
I did this guy's so I can get the rook
involved
yeah and we win twenty moves we win
definitely do our etske endgame you
should study that's probably for 2200
players and up I agree definitely
opening work you have to work on your
openings
the question you know to become a two
thousand openings middle game definitely
well I'll play a GM if any GM challenges
me I don't know if do we have any GM's
in the queue
I can accept their challenge I enjoy
playing GM's but let's see if we have
any how do we know if it's a GM I don't
I don't know if we have any GM guys
[Music]
so let's see here let's go back
all right we'll get some more games in
here we go over the questions if there
are more questions all right let's see
guys let's get one more game in we have
71 people in line guys we a lot of
people who want to play but well we'll
see how many we can get in okay well I
go by the you know people who've been
waiting so when I give you know you know
them a chance to where let's see
all right so what do we have here let's
try this a five month with idea a for
put some pressure right from the get-go
from the get-go we put pressure on that
bishop
ninety-four
take
like where five playing a little bit
risky here but it's okay I mean we just
we're still fine we have two bishops
all right it's good this Bishop here I
want to bring the bishop to h5 guys
cake
25
Oh draw offert my opponent offered me a
draw guys but we're gonna play on okay
it's uh there's no point in taking a
draw here it's uh it's an interesting
position to play well I want to keep the
Queens on the board I don't know let's
see maybe play some g5 ideas
all right let's trade he just keeps
trying to trade Quinn's not sure if it's
very good for him but he is trying it
let's see
take
thank you thank you from T sick thank
you for the compliment
I'm glad you enjoy my games well you got
it you got a challenge there st. Louis
chess club account only chess and and I
will pick you know so and I will accept
your challenge so here we're gonna go
after this pawn here now okay we take
desk guy we go here
well I'm accepting anybody who is in
line so we we got 66 people in line
right now so we got a lot of people who
want to play check
yeah I probably didn't play the best way
but still should be winning
and when you're ahead guys again we're
never afraid to trade
wow this guy's still playing alright
let's finish him off
oh wow okay resigned let's see okay
let's see if we have some more
interesting questions
yeah 94 to prevent Bishop C - yeah but
that's it was a tough endgame for him
anyway yes I speak Russian I do I speak
you know understand I can read pretty
fluent in Russian let's see what else
yeah you got to develop your pieces
absolutely
I could play Kings gambit I could try
that for fun all right let's see let's
see what we have here going on we got
more players in line so let's give
everybody a chance to play gambit
okay let's do a gambit guys let's see if
you place a five we'll play f4 will play
the Kings gambit because of the requests
we had so people asked me to play some
gambits so we can do that oh all right
so see Julian Wow
all right I like this line against the
Chilean let me show you what I like
against the Chilean here b3 yeah
Vladimir Kramnik play this beat removing
a very nice game against Judit Polgar
also not again to look to his Akopian my
friend Vladimir Akopian against Garry
Kasparov 2002 it was a rapid game but
Vladimir Akopian won and like 25 miles
is a very good game to look at it so I
guess I should have played Bishop b5 I
shoulda play Bishop b5 first and then
there should be two but but it's okay
so
yeah we have a lot of friends all over
the world watching us from Greece we
have greetings I have been in Greece
once I played in a European huge
championship in 1999 a long time ago and
I I won the bronze medal I remember so
it was a good experience in Greece
that's the only time I was there exactly
20 years ago take
I don't really play chess that much
every day I'm very busy teaching my
students a lot of students private
students so I do that
so ok D for now I play here a four to
play a 93 but I enjoy playing night 83
now the point is to go to c4 we got
international a lot of people from
Tunisia from Germany from India
Argentina Albania I haven't been to
Albania Tirana yeah the capital of Iran
and I haven't been there no that's
that's on my list you know to do to try
to travel to some of the cool countries
that I haven't been to in Europe and and
all over the world I've been to about 50
countries so I I really enjoy traveling
and playing chess and meeting you know
chess friends and fans all over the
world I have a lot of students you know
in different countries and enjoy
visiting with them Latvia I know I
haven't been to Latvia actually that's
on the list I haven't been to the
Baltics you know I need to visit Latvia
Lithuania and Estonia that's on the list
that's that's what I'm missing so okay
we got it we got a huge advantage here
guys the bishop is coming to d2 now Cuba
yeah
Cuba is on a list as well guys I'm
looking forward to visit Cuba I was
invited to play the Capablanca memorial
twice but I couldn't go because I had
other commitments but I'm looking
forward to visit Cuba it's you know it's
definitely on my list and I have some
friends from Cuba chess players and
really like the people from there so you
know looking forward to visit Havana and
a few other places
my opponent is thinking a lot guys so
this is tough you know Moscow I've been
to Moscow many times I always enjoy
Moscow and I have relatives who live
there and you know as I mentioned I
speak the language so it's always a
pleasure to go back to to Russia all
right what do we do here guys so we have
a nice position so play g3 with night h4
Knight f5 ideas and now night h4
threatening to go to a5 let's see what
its opponent gonna do I currently have
some grand master students guys so I
work with a lot of very top players I
you know it ranges my students ranging I
have students from like 6 years old
you know kids who are just learning how
to play and I teach them the
fundamentals you know putting the proper
proper you know fundamentals for the
game and I up to grandmasters 25 plus
rate 2500 plus rated players who are
aspiring to be a 2600 or you know go
forward so I the range of my students it
varies
I don't have the thing that I don't take
certain students know if I have
availability I feel like I can help this
person I will I will I will accept him
as a student and you know I expect them
to to work hard and you know to do their
homework assignments and follow my
guidance to achieve their goals and
chests so every time I take on a new
student it's like a very interesting
experience new new challenge for me to
help this person to achieve his goals so
so I'm quite busy these days with my
students and other teaching projects I
do so now yeah this this came didn't
quite go well for my opponent as you can
see in our position it's just falling
apart now we are winning a queen also
we're not gonna win on time but we're
gonna win the game guys so this was a
pretty nice game and I played ephors
just to mix things up for you guys
so you can see
yeah exchanging winning so with e4 let's
see let's see Morocco let's see I
haven't been to Sweden but that's on the
list as well I would like to definitely
visit Sweden I've only been to Norway
from the Scandinavian countries so
that's something on the list to visit
Sweden and what do you know about
Morocco I was in Morocco actually I was
in Tangier Morocco last year at a great
time it was just the one day one day
tour but really enjoy it it was really
beautiful yeah let's see here let's see
if all right to play let's see yeah I
somebody yeah you helped me about
lessons well yeah yeah if you're
interested you can always email me guys
and I will respond to you and see if I
can help you
definitely I don't know any strong blind
chess players I'm sure they're out there
there is a team at Olympia today there
is a special team of blind players I
think they have some I am Ceylon but I
don't know them exactly but there is a
team I believe let's see here we got
about 10 minutes little bit more left
guys so I know there's still a lot of
people in line here we want to play
yeah I'm sorry if we didn't get to you
this time but make sure you tune in and
get in the queue for next week ok and
we'll you know and we'll get you in here
we're gonna go one more game here and we
got an opponent so let's play another
efore guys mix things up here for our
reef or friends who don't play d4 they
want to see me play Sammy force I can
definitely play that too I enjoy playing
new openings it's a lot of work to play
a four against you know so
hiring player you have to know a lot of
theories so but I do enjoy it so let's
see now how this game is gonna go
well I don't know what's happening my
opponent is not moving and the clock is
not going so we'll see
so you for
so yeah I guess we'll abort this game
then yeah since the clock is not going
we'll probably have to abort this one
and see who else is out there okay we
have 2000 rated opponent let's play
efore 2069 sit silly and defense so
let's take a look all right we'll play
the same line did a kramnik polgár game
right maybe should be fire first now I
will play this way the a copyin game
against Kasparov from 2002 guys and
definitely recommend you look at that
it's a really really good game here the
ship here
okay so what are we doing here we're
gonna call c4 we can try to get d4 in
[Music]
kewal
oof I didn't expect a five I don't know
it looks a little bit dangerous
you know take
we're gonna take
where are we gonna go here for we're
gonna try to break the center here guys
we're taking advantage of the fact that
the opponent King is in the middle of
the board let's see
we have some more questions here let's
see um
gambit well
well who is the top trip player where we
we got a US team is very strong right
now I mean we have
we have work Fabiano Caruana
clearly and then we have Wesley so
linear Dominguez so us chess is very
very strong right now
all right let's even let a check here to
see what is
how are we gonna get bring the rook to
f1 and then a bishop is an account to
see one guys
I'll probably answer some questions
after this guy's this after this game
let's see we get a bishop on h6 if
possible
Bishop on h6 will be very nice so that's
what I'm trying to do and I also want to
play the move a fourth to stop opponent
from pushing so now I'm gonna stop his
control a
now as you can see the position is very
strong
threaten queen h6
the plan is just to push the deep on now
these 67
and we win this game guys thank you
everybody for playing it's a lot of fun
so last few minutes I'll go over some
answers some comments here so let's see
how you maintain forming chests you just
have to keep playing and practicing
study the openings so you have to you
have to you know chess if you can play
every day that will be good and I
recommend you play longer games and you
know when you get comfortable you can
play more faster games how to purchase
my course learning online Benjamin a
meaning Benjamin I mean is that how to
purchase your course which I'm not sure
which course you're referring to
I provide private lessons online if you
can specify which course you have I have
I have many students distant students
that I train absolutely online we use
Skype and we use you know different
chess platforms ICC chess calm or Lee
chess for the lessons I my coach has
been International Hashanah dannion he
is really famous coach in Armenia he
worked with a lot of top players so he's
really really good coach I am NOT
dannion you can look him up that was it
was my coach let's see here next session
guys is gonna be next to Thursday at 3
o'clock Central Time so so make sure you
tune in for that so we had a lot of lot
of fun today playing I have worked for
ya have you worked as a second for any
top player yes I have I have worked as a
second for a very very strong top player
preparing for the candidates tournament
I won't be able to reveal his name but I
have worked for top 3 player in the
world so I can just tell you that
so I'm very experienced with a very high
level of opening preparation that kind
of work as well yes I do remember going
to the La Palma chess club definitely
that was when I just moved to us in 2001
play one of my first tournaments in La
Palma chess club when I just moved to us
a long time ago let's see here to play
blitz better you just got to make sure
you put your piss on a natural scores
that's the idea just to make sure you
don't have loose pieces and hanging
pieces put them on a protected squares
do I do I believe if Dingley Ren is the
future world champion very possible I
mean he is proving that you know he can
play against Magnus and you know in a
tie-break sea be defeating him so it's a
very good chance we might see the
England play him at some point for the
world championship very possible very
possible absolutely I recommend Grand
Master regards books there are great
books I personally use them to work on
my game and train my top students so
it's got great books how do you manage
time I mean you just have to try to
manage your clock properly I mean I do
get into time trouble sometimes
sometimes that's due to openings so but
yeah definitely you have to manage your
clock wisely what do I think of Kostya
Kowalski I have trained Kostya Kowalski
I am caustic of Otsuki now and he's when
it was about 1600 really player in LA
and my team all the way to up to like
2200 and then he trained on his own and
became and I am so it's very very proud
of him so he was one of my you know
first students that I work with so it
was a lot of fun working with Kostya
yeah as far as the prediction yeah I
think most likely I'm predicting for
Dingle Arendt to win it or MDL but I
think probably dink is the favorite okay
thank you everybody for what you know
for watching the stream and playing
sorry if I didn't get to play all of you
it's just you know we run out of time it
was a lot of fun and make sure you tune
in next Thursday at 3 o'clock Central
Time
and we'll continue playing okay and
analyzing games all right take care